my best friend in college Laura schulsen
was working she's a little bit older
than me so she was working in a uh
advert at an advertising agency now
she's like one of the heads of one of
the big advertising agencies edit that
out and it hopefully I just had her
promotion we don't correct I have her
card I was going to pass out in case you
need any advertising her LinkedIn link
any agencies
um she's like I have an audition for you
for like a commercial Like Money
commercial and this was the days when
big money oh life-changing money somehow
who knocked on us you know the actors
are making a lot of money on commercials
who stopped that why and where did it go
where did it go like the money was
discussing that it's like big big
celebrities are getting it they're
saving it all for that
like podcasting suffers the same thing
it's like some guy in New Hampshire used
to be able to start his podcast okay and
you know review films and now he's
competing with you know uh [__] oh I
had it on the tip of Jason Bateman homes
I thought you thought your name uh I
give it up that was Jason yes yeah
keep going so celebs are taking all the
maybe I don't know big cheddar but at
the time this was like oh my God I'm
gonna audition for a commercial and uh
also sort of felt by the way side note a
little bit like I don't know if I want
to do commercials like I'm an actress I
do theater so young now hilarious that
you were like hilarious rolling your own
drum cigarettes yeah I'm like I don't
know yeah would Steppenwolf do it right
exactly uh so I I but I you know I
lowered myself to to go to the audition
no I wanted it so bad of course it would
have been your year oh uh it would have
been my month my year How does it go
it's friends you're just playing along
have you ever seen my year it's 365 days
my dear have you ever seen my week this
is a different show I've never seen
seven of them you freak okay write that
down
right idea for sitcom put it on Spotify
it makes six cents a year okay okay so
that's what got you I
going to this audition and this is my
first time ever auditioning for a
commercial and I don't know if this is
still how they do it but the audition
the commercials they're called spots and
they have titles right but the title
doesn't often uh completely correlate so
this particular title
said mime
so imagine my delight
because I was taking mime at New York
University oh NYU mime school no
actually and when I went to school of
the arts I was an experimental theater
major but one of my elective classes was
mime so I thought you know I'm a college
I'm like you know so you're soaking up
full of myself I'm soaking it all up and
I'm like mime I got this like I'm gonna
pull out the my moves like you've never
seen yeah
not just pulling a rope
I'm pull okay so I go in I'm stretching
in the bathroom because this is really
going to be something
and I am
um in this description it says mime and
then it says there's a voice over and
I'm simply reacting
to the voiceover I don't speak what is
the product
phone of Verizon some some phone service
okay
mimes have no need for that I guess I
could text right well they couldn't
because this is a pretense
landline this is landline days you only
needs a phone to kill another mime
that's right yeah uh you ever beat
someone on the phone
[Music]
it's a great Implement Let's Get Down
two-edged so you can yeah so I am
pulling out all of the mime yeah that I
that I have learned in my two months of
deep mime Deep dive I'm pulling ropes
I am catching birds I am stuck in a box
I'm stuck in a box with a bird I'm
pulling a rope I'm pulling a box oh
there's wind this way there's wind this
way there's wind from above wind in the
box where the road the Box there's wind
taking the bird yeah oh the thing you
wouldn't believe
um
and I finished this tour de force
performance and I'm wow they're doing
the voiceover they're reading it they're
reading the voiceover
and I'm sweating I'm giving it my all
because even if I you know if they don't
pick me at least I want them to say like
wow that was really something like are
there awards for just auditions because
I was sure I was going to get dishes
the weird girl who did 45 minutes of
mine
or the best mime you've ever seen oh
yeah and here to deliver her non-speech
yes so I think
and I look up
and I swear to God I have never seen
more
confusion
Panic like I felt like I saw some like
fear horror horror
and just silence
even my friend who's in the in the back
they were there she was there and she's
like this like can I rewrite this memory
in your mind and she has a cigarette and
yes almost all the way and that's loud
that cuts to her and the ash Falls so
she's just yeah and you hear it because
it's so quiet the ash
and you're like and then should I be
able to hear Ash right now she has a
little dog and the dog goes
perfect perfect
I'll even pitch monocle falls off into
teacup into teacup
yes cool cool
the official sound of a upper class
person who's offended yes
[Music]
yes onto a fainting couch that's what
they're there for sure Shea's Lounge
all of those things happened
and I was
like okay and is there anything else
that you want to see or no that's we're
great thank you so okay keep going I
have so many questions but I want to
hear what you're getting so did I yeah
because I just gave you what more could
you want yeah
I go home you gave them a Tour de France
sure sure
my girlfriend without all the bikes and
stuff yeah
my girl I was going for tour de force of
France which is a thing so it doesn't
work I was like you're my real tour to
France and you're like leave the bikes
you want to check that riff for double
meetings no I'll just say Tour de France
I actually thought it was a super riff
that you knew it was two or four so then
you took it once you were doing a bit on
a bit no mime's French tour de force
Tour de France yeah and and then I went
there was a red light that went off in
my riff computer this means something
else and I went just say it anymore Jazz
more jazz or Jazz well it's actually
it's a deep trust I was like even if I
say something that doesn't make sense
I'll get it I'll pick it up curve big
insult so uh I got home and my
girlfriend calls me and and I'm like how
did it go and she's like Carrie what
happened
and I was like what do you mean and she
said um I just have to say like that was
the funniest
thing that's like we were dying
and I said what do you mean what why
what she said you oh you weren't trying
to be funny I said no she said we were
just stunned
at your choice and I said what do you
mean
and I said it said mime and she's like I
know but you weren't supposed to
literally be a mime you just were
supposed to react like your reaction
like not talking like a wordless
reaction
so I see this thing on TV
like months later and literally this is
the performance by the person who got
the part I'm ready so you do the
voiceover yeah not cell phones just
Verizon home phone right Verizon home
phone can Now cover two lines per your
house here that means you can have a
business line and a person online you
are making the smallest for just the
audio people the smallest
subdued nod with a smile just like a hmm
hmm maybe there was one not like like
yeah yeah two nods was too much for this
person
why did you call him mine yeah why I
called my call it not and smile not and
smile that would have been giving it
away
[Music]